barty krauts jr i'll show you mine if
you show me yours
from dukes to dancers we didn't
recognize
any of them in their hogwarts robes some
of our favorite actors were just working
as extras only a few years ago
who went from being a background actor
to a netflix star what about the game of
thrones star who briefly appeared in one
of the last films
let's see all the actors who've been
under our noses this whole time
professor moody what are you doing here
rescuing you of course
once we saw this we could never unsee it
how is it that the bridgeton star was a
background actor in harry potter and the
deathly hallows part 1.
we can see his handsome face looking
onto the wedding of bill and fleur
just behind hermione little did he know
it's his romance
and bridgeton that everyone's eyes would
be on guess he really took the whole
there are no small parts sentiment
seriously
i assure you i'm just a regular guy
paige can also be spotted on screen in
the film sylvie's love and mortal
engines
keepers need to be quick agile
i like my chances apparently there is no
part too big or too small for actor
freddie stroma who appeared in a small
part as cormick mclagan
a gryffindor quidditch player in the
final two harry potter movies
while he had a bit part in the hogwarts
world we can't say the same for his
other projects like game of thrones
unreal and bridgerton he also managed to
steal the show in pitch perfect as the
radio station manager at barton u
we often forget about pansy parkinson
the slytherin witch who dated draco
briefly
what are you waiting for someone grab
him though
now that we know who played the part
it'll be hard for us to forget
scarlet byrne has had all kinds of major
roles like nora hildegard and the
vampire diaries and bronwyn and marvel's
runaways
as for her dating life she definitely
upgraded from draco who mostly ignored
her once she married hugh hefner's son
cooper hefner
we were very surprised to learn that
luke youngblood who's probably best
known for playing magnitude in the show
community
was a young wizard once upon a time in
both harry potter and the philosopher's
stone and the chamber of secrets
the actor who also played young simba in
the stage production of the lion king in
london
actually had a character name in the
films too now it'll be hard to forget
the young gryffindor named
lee jordan it's a bit shocking to
realize we didn't notice some of the
very successful actors that have
appeared in harry potter
hello harry bill weasley donald gleason
is
definitely at the top of this list the
irish actor writer and director has been
nominated for a tony award and has
appeared in
countless tv shows and movies most
notably as general hux in star wars the
force awakens and the last jedi
how did we never know until now that he
played bill weasley
to add to the surprise we learned that
his famous dad
brendan gleeson also appeared in the
same harry potter film as alistair moody
apparently the younger gleason wasn't
too crazy about the idea of being in a
film with his dad but
went along with it anyway maddow is dead
wait caitlin stark of game of thrones
was in harry potter
while we thought it may have been in one
of the earlier films when we didn't
quite know her face yet we were
so very wrong turns out actor michelle
fairley was the one who betrayed
hermione's mom for the briefest of
moments in harry potter and the deathly
hallows part 1.
an important part but very easy to miss
we didn't miss her when she was in suits
playing ava hessington or on the show
misfits though
don't call me nymph fedora
how did we never notice all these game
of thrones stars in harry potter movies
before
for natalie tanna we can chalk it up to
the hair and costumes she wore as
nymphadora tonks
she appeared in the order of phoenix the
half-blood prince and the deathly
hallows and not
once did we recognize her the actress
also appeared in the youtube thriller
called origin with fellow harry potter
alumni
tom felton we loved watching her as miss
harrison and ninola holmes
carolyn martens and killing eve and
marnie stonebrook and trueblood
and now we know that she was not in one
but
multiple harry potter movies that's
right she was the actor who played on
petunia in the films
i was the only one to see her for what
she was
[Applause]
moaning myrtle is by far one of the most
memorable characters in the harry potter
movies
she steals the show in every scene the
actor is a master of disguise since she
was playing a part much younger than she
actually was
well depending on how you look at the
age of a ghost
let's all throw books at myrtle because
she can't feel it
henderson was the oldest actor to have
played a hogwarts student at the age of
35.
the next time we watch bridget jones's
diary we won't be able to get moaning
myrtle out of our heads
yep that's the same actress
it wasn't even that small apart but
let's just say that the bobaton blue
made clemons poesie harder to recognize
not to mention the fact that she was
underwater for part of the first film
she appeared in
poezi played fleur de la cour the goblet
of fire and the final two deathly
hallows films
you saved her even though she wasn't
used to save
my little sister she was brilliant in
the part but
it's hard to believe she's the same
actress that played eva coupo
on gossip girl jaime campbell bauer
is pretty special considering the fact
that he's the only actor to have
reprised his role from harry potter in
the fantastic beasts film
he made a very quick appearance in harry
potter and the deathly hallows part one
as a young
gelert grindelwald his somewhat regal
and magical roles don't stop there
though
bauer also played pius and twilight and
king arthur and camelot
up next we can catch him as peter
ballard in stranger things
frank delane is a bit famous for being a
johnny depp doppelganger
but he can definitely disguise himself
well since his portrayal of tom riddle
in the harry potter films
is about as far away from looking like
deaf as you can get
i read something rather odd about a bit
of rare magic
it's called horcrux he was only 16 when
he got the part
so now that he's more grown up we can
understand why we didn't recognize him
right off the bat
the actor has an impressive list of
credits besides the younger version of
he who shall not be named
including a role on the show sensate the
heart of the sea
and fear the walking dead his dad
stephen delane is another recognizable
actor who we've come to know as stannis
barithian
in game of thrones warwick davis
is so flexible an actor he actually
played a whopping
three different roles in the harry
potter movies does mr harry potter have
his key
yes we said three would you believe us
if we said that professor flitwick
one of the goblin bank tellers and
griphop were all
the same person davis had his work cut
out for him
when he isn't busy juggling multiple
roles in the wizarding worlds he can be
seen playing wicket w
warwick in star wars the rise of
skywalker and in maleficent as
lickspittle david tennant showed off his
incredible acting skills portraying a
detective in broad church alongside
olivia coleman
as kilgrave and jessica jones and most
notably the doctor and doctor who
with so many leading roles we were
surprised to know that he appeared in
the harry potter world without us even
realizing
hello father tennant played barty crouch
jr
and was actually only on set for about
10 days over the course of one year of
shooting
ravenclaw i had the tie the scarf had
the robe
the professional dancer siblings
julianne and derek huff are no strangers
to the performance world
but we were definitely surprised to
learn that they were both in harry
potter and the philosopher's stone as
extras
julianne took to the screen as a
gryffindor student and derek as a
ravenclaw with an owl
julianne huff actually tried to take the
gryffindor scarf she wore on set with
her but wound up not being able to keep
it
she did have a pretty big crush on
daniel radcliffe so maybe that answers
some questions as to why the siblings
took to the screen
it's going to be pretty hard for us to
watch any of the harry potter films
without trying to find the familiar
faces of these stars now
we're still reeling over the fact that
our favorite duke
reggae jean paige was in the background
all this time